Hi everyone, we are very excited
to bring you a whole new
season of "Fate and Fabled."
Hang tight to the end
of this episode
where we'll be
revealing a fun surprise
for the upcoming
season, stay tuned.
Gather round, ye nerds and
weirdos, to hear this epic tale
of a godly war where
each side goes,
"I think we just might fail."
(host 2)
In old Norse lore,
a witch was burned,
not once, nor twice, but thrice.
On her behalf,
the war tide turned
and each side paid the price.
Cue years of war before
a fragile peace could be agreed,
till one side's anger was
unleashed, misunderstood indeed.
But wisdom won, did Odin roar,
"Hey, spit in this cup here,"
and thus added the vicious war
between the Aesir and the Vanir.
[mystical music]
How do you end a war
between gods?
With spit, of course.
In Norse mythology,
two competing groups
of gods called the Aesir
and the Vanir fought
a devastating war
until they combined their saliva
to cement a remarkably
unique truce.
Divine wars aren't rare.
They can be found in
most mythologies
from around the world.
The Greek Olympians fought
and defeated the Titans.
The Hindu Devas were able
to banish the demonic Asuras
to something that
resembled hell.
And Christian angels cast
the rebellious demons down
into actual hell.
These conflicts usually end
with good triumphant over evil,
a reminder to us
mortals of what happens
when you stray from
the righteous path.
But the war between the Aesir
and Vanir is different
because it doesn't
impose a moral hierarchy.
Instead, the two groups combined
into a single united pantheon.
Maybe the Norse just like
some different story tropes,
but some scholars
think this myth
can provide insight into the
actual history of Scandinavia.
How about we tell you the story
and then you can decide
for yourself what it means?
To understand
the Aesir and Vanir,
let's take a closer look
at how Norse mythology
is structured.
The universe, according
to Norse mythology,
is split up into nine
different worlds,
resting in the roots
and branches
of the Great Tree Yggdrasil.
Each world is inhabited
by a different race,
like the giants on Jotunheim
and the dwarves on Svartalfheim
and the wee blue folk
of Smurfheim.
Okay, I made that last one up.
But we humans lived on Midgard
and worshiped two
other races as gods,
the Vanir of Vanaheim
and the Aesir of Asgard.
The Vanir used their powerful
magic to help humans prosper
in agriculture,
wealth, and fertility.
They were wise, thoughtful,
and wielded a coveted
magic called Seidr,
which could foresee
and shape the future.
The Aesir, on the other hand,
were more interested
in violence and war than
their magical counterparts.
For them,
brute strength, bravery,
and loyalty were valued
above most other traits.
[soft music]
Hail, nerd, whatcha doing?
I'm gardening,
meathead, I'm a Vanir.
I inspire the humans on Midgard
to grow crops and
gain more wealth.
Well, I am an Aesir
and I incite the humans
towards violence and war.
Weird flex. I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna get more respect
for what I do.
You would think that,
wouldn't you?
Most sources say the war started
as retaliation for an Aesir
act of cowardly violence.
One section from "The Poetic
Edda" tells us about Gullveig,
a witch goddess who
traveled to Asgard
and shared her magic
with the Aesir.
She gave the Aesir gifts,
granted their wishes
and brought prosperity to
the All Father Odin's Hall,
for which the Aesir
were totally grateful.
I'm just kidding.
These are the gods of violence
and war we're talking about.
They feared that Gullveig's
generosity was making them soft
and complacent or gold drunk,
which is one
translation of her name.
So they decided to kill her,
first with spears,
and when that didn't work
they burned her at
the stake three times
and three times she was reborn
from the ashes
thanks to her magic.
They renamed her Heidr,
meaning Bright One.
The texts don't specify where
this powerful woman came from
or what she wanted.
One possible theory
is that Gullveig
was a Vanir goddess
Freya in disguise.
This is just one moment in
the story where it splits
into multiple versions, just
like Marvel's many multiverses.
(host 1)
Obviously, the Vanir
couldn't let this treatment
of one of their
own go unpunished.
So they uncharacteristically
readied for war,
but the Aesir were always
prepared for battle.
So when Odin learned
about the Vanir's plans
he was able to strike first.
The two groups met
on the plain of war,
the same field where the
final battle in Ragnarok
was predestined to take place,
and Odin threw the first
spear into enemy lines.
The Eddas and other
remaining records
of Norse lore don't provide
many details about the war
but imply that it was
devastating for both sides.
After the first battle,
the Vanir used their magic
to decimate the protective
walls that encircled Asgard.
And later, when the gods hire
a giant to rebuild the wall,
Loki will shapeshift
into a lady horse
and distract
the giant's stallion
so he can't finish
the job on time
and won't have to be paid
Freya's hand in marriage.
Known as
the "Bugs Bunny Gambit,"
it seems like a risky way
to get out of paying a bill.
In return, the Aesir absolutely
wrecked the Vanir homestead
with the battle prowess
that inspired centuries
of Viking raids.
War waged for years with magic
and physical strength taking
turns on the upper hand,
potions bested axes,
swords sliced through spells.
Eventually the two sides
realized they were at an impasse
and met to call a ceasefire.
-Well, that was fun.
-Was it?
Yeah, I mean, maybe
we should join forces.
With my bravery and strength
and your magic,
we could be like
the best pantheon ever.
Like the Justice League meets--
-The Avengers.
-I was gonna say Care Bears.
Oh yeah, that's fair.
(host 2)
In the longstanding Germanic
and Scandinavian tradition,
each side cemented
the truce by sending some
of their own to live
with their former foes.
The Vanir sent Freya,
her brother Freyr,
and their father Njord
to live among the Aesir,
while Hoenir and Mimir were
sent to live on Vanaheim.
The three Vanirs settled
well into life on Asgard.
But Hoenir and Mimir
weren't so fortunate.
At first, the Vanir were so
enchanted by Hoenir's good looks
and wisdom that they
made him their leader.
But when they found out
that Hoenir was just a dope
who was getting his
advice advice from Mimir,
they were so mad that
they cut off Mimir's head
and sent it to Daddy Odin.
Odin used the seidr magic
that Vanir taught him
to keep meme's head alive
and thankfully avoided
another all-out war.
The decapitation was written off
as nothing more than
a misunderstanding.
I mean, who among us
hasn't gotten confused
and lopped off
a former enemy's head?
The Aesir and Vanir gathered
once more and debated,
according to the "Voluspa" poem,
"Whether the gods
should tribute give
or to all alike
should worship belong?"
The Vanir wanted
either compensation
for the way Gullveig
had been treated
or equal worship by the humans.
No more of this
"also featuring" bull.
The Aesir agreed to
share their divine status
and the two groups
secured their peace
by spitting into a cauldron.
From the spit emerged
the god Kvasir,
the wisest of all beings
whose blood became the
legendary mead of poetry.
We don't know why spit was used
to seal such a momentous
decision, but I love
that the practice lives on
in the modern spit shake.
To the Aesir and Vanir!
[inhales]
Wait, why not to
the Vanir and Aesir?
It's alphabetical.
Oh.
So why is the ending
to this war so unique?
It's possible this story
and its spitty conclusion
where merely adopted and adapted
from proto Indo-European
cultures as they intermingled.
But I'm personally
not convinced.
The story's ending is
too unlike other myths
from the region.
Instead, I agree with
historians like Dr. John Lindow,
that this myth acts as
a blurred reflection
of real world events.
We've talked about this
phenomenon on the show before.
An influential person or local
hero might be exaggerated
into a god like the
Yoruba King Shango,
who was deified as an Orisha
or a clash of cultures
could be remembered
as a legendary war, much like
the six invasions described
in the Irish
"Mythological Cycle."
Here, the hypothesis is that
Germanic tribes migrated north
about 3,000 years ago,
encountered
indigenous Scandinavians
with their own
differing pantheon
and incorporated it
into their own.
We know that ancient
Germanic tribes
worshiped a war god named Wodin.
And Roman records tell us that
they were skilled fighters
so it's easy to imagine them
following the war
hungry Aesir gods,
but not the seidr
wielding Vanir.
It seems much more likely
that the Vanir were worshiped
by indigenous Scandinavians
who placed more
of a societal emphasis on
connecting to the land.
The Sami people, native to what
is now Northern Scandinavia,
had a shamanic religion
before they were Christianized
in the 16th century, and
their shamanic practices
might have been
mythologized as seidr.
Their relationship with the land
could have yielded a pantheon
of Vanir-like agriculture
and fertility deities.
I say "might" and "could"
because unfortunately little
is known about this
region's history
due to a lack of written records
and a climate that tends to
destroy archeological artifacts.
Regardless of the myth's origin,
the war between the Aesir and
Vanir is a powerful reminder
that conflicts rooted
in anger and fear
can still be resolved
through wisdom and mercy.
In that spirit, we've
cooked up a fun treat for you
in this season of
"Fate and Fabled."
Dr. McT and I have
each picked five
of our favorite
figures from mythology.
It's kind of like
a fantasy football draft,
but without
all the toxic competition.
We'll reveal one of our choices
in each thematically
appropriate episode,
and at the end of the season,
we'll unite our pantheons
just like the Norse did.
So to start us off, Dr. McT,
who's your first pick?
Oh, I'm so excited
for you to hear this.
I am choosing Idunn.
-Do you know Idunn?
-Ooh, no.
Idunn is an Aesir, she's
a goddess of fertility
and spring and rejuvenation,
but she's in charge of
planting the golden apples
that the Aesir used to stay
immortal and beautiful.
That sounds like
something I want.
So I definitely
approve of this pick.
Thank you! I do like the
option of living forever,
so I wanted to give the people
in our little utopia
that option.
And the more gold
the better, in my book.
Exactly.
[ominous music]
Excellent first pick
to start us off.
I'll be making my first
pick of the pantheon
at the end of the next episode,
but make sure you stay tuned
for every episode this season.
We'll reveal our pantheon
picks at the end of each.
But maybe you'll remember
that better in verse.
Is there any of that
poetry mead left?
-Yes, there you go.
-Thank you.
(Emily)
Ten gods chosen, five apiece,
from the world around.
(Moiya)
In sky or sea
or deep dark pit
could they all be found.
(Emily)
We'll share the tales
of people
whose lives our choices touched
and set aside the differences
that once they may have clutch.
So stick around this season.
We promise you won't yawn
once you see who we draft
in our fantasy pantheon.
Hey foodies, you're missing out
if you're not watching
the new stuff cooking
over on PBS Food.
Go on a tasty journey to find
the best South Asian food
in America on "Spice Road"
or get ready to swap
delicious recipes
from different
cultures on "Pan Pals."
The channel has shows
covering the history
of iconic dishes
to food science.
Hit the link in our
description to check them out.
Just don't watch these
on an empty stomach.
I would wear this outfit though.
I low-key would actually
probably wear this.
-Yeah.
-Wait, wait, wait.
Why not to the
Vaesir and the Anir?
That's not what they're called.
Uh-oh.